just got to count you down
german five four three
two one and you're
live chairman thank you thank you
good evening and welcome to this central
area planning committee meeting
on wednesday 2nd of december 2020
my name is councillor michael edwards i
am the chairman of this committee
this meeting is held under new
regulations which came into effect
on the 4th of april in response to the
kovic 19 situation
and there are just a few housekeeping
issues to run through first of all
please could i ask everyone present in
this meeting to ensure
your microphone remains muted and your
video feed
off when not addressing the committee
this will reduce background noises
and avoid any unintentional disturbances
this meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed
live and recorded and by being present
in this meeting you are giving your
consent to being the recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the chat function of the
meeting
to indicate if you wish to speak i will
then invite you at the appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
indicating you wish to speak or that you
have to leave the meeting
the check function should not be used
for questions or any other purpose
please do not use the raise hand
function
as this is not available on all members
devices
when speaking and referring to the
agenda papers please ensure you
reference a page or paragraph number
and lastly if members need to leave the
meeting
at any point please do make this known
and use the chat function to signify
that you need to leave the meeting now
may i ask officers taking part in the
meeting
to introduce themselves starting with mr
lee
good evening chairman and committee i am
matthew lee
lead specialist place and chief planning
officer of morden district council thank
you
thank you
catherine matthews
good evening chairman um i'm catherine
mathews i'm a specialist and
development management officer and for
the council thank you
thank you hannah duncan
good evening chairman um i'm hannah
dungay i am planning specialist
in development management thank you
thank you sophia margin
good evening chairman i'm sophie martin
i am a planning caseworker at mdc thank
you
thank you bernard casey good evening
chairman
i'm briana casey talked to this
evening's committee thank you
thank you are there any other officers
present
no chairman thank you
berna please can you now carry out a
roll call of members
to confirm who is attendance thank you
thank you chairman members i will call
your names in alphabetical order can you
please indicate that you're in
attendance
starting with councillor miss a.m beale
good evening chairman i'm here um but
just to let you know i haven't got a
chat function so you'll see my hand go
up
thank you councillor edwards president
thank you councillor heard
good evening chairman good evening
bernard i am present
thank you councillor lagan
yeah very good evening everybody i'm
present thank you
councillor mays present burner
thank you councillor morris good evening
and welcome
thank you councillor nunn yes here berna
um good evening good evening chair good
evening uh members
thank you caster shaunicy
um yes present good evening everyone
thank you
stilts
good evening yes present thank you
cancer swain
yes good evening present
thank you members uh now may i ask those
members in attendance if there are any
to introduce themselves please
have we any members in attendance i
think we have counsellor hall
perhaps right i'm in prison
hello everybody
so we have cancer hall and sorry can i
just have a repeat of the second person
oh sorry that's a member of the public
thank you very much thank you very much
councillor
hull thank you chairman that concludes
the roll call
thank you vernon agenda item two
apologies for absence may i have the
apologies for absence please bernard
uh chairman we've received no apologies
for absence thank you we've got full
attendance
thank you item three minutes
of the 4th of november 2020
uh it is recommended that the minutes of
the meeting held on the 4th of november
2020 found on pages 7 to 10
are approved as a true and accurate
record
i so move if you wish to second that
motion please turn on your video
unmute your microphone and state your
name now counselor none seconded
thank you councillor none um if any
member wishes to raise any matter of
accuracy please use the chat function to
indicate and are
invited to speak
berna please can you advise if any other
member has indicated a wish to speak
no chairman
bernie will now take the vote please
taking each member in alphabetical order
uh for or against or abstain absolution
sorry abstain or do does the committee
wish to agree the minutes
by ascent agreed
agree thank you agreed
thank you item for declarations of
interest
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disposable pecuniary
interests other ficunary interests or
non-binary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda and will regret
regarding paragraphs six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
news arise throughout the meeting
if any member has an interest to declare
please use the chat function now
syndicate
and i will invite you to speak
yes chairman counselor nun
thank you bernie thank you chairman uh
yes item 798 washington road
uh i'm acquainted with the applicant
thank you
thank you
councillor shaunicy and i think
councillor mays has her hand up as well
yes thank you bono um
thank you thank you ben thank you
chairman um yes
um non-pecuniary um i have had emails
um from the um lady at 98 washington
road
um and emails from neighbours as well
thank you
chairman and counselor heard
yeah thank you burner uh non-pecuniary
um item
seven um 98 washington road as i know
the children of the applicant
thank you
council heard
thank you chairman uh that i've had
telephone calls from some objections
objectives thank you
that concludes everybody chairman thank
you very much
item five then
planning application twenty stroke zero
zero
seven nine six full application 119 high
street modern essex
we moved to item agenda item five with
this panic application
found on pages 11 to 26 please note that
a
member's update in relation to this
application has also been circulated
prior to the meeting
in a moment i will call on the officer
to present this item
members a reminder that if you wish to
speak on this item please make this
known by using the check function within
this meeting
i will then come to you in turn and
please keep your points clear and
succinct
uh mr miss matt miss matthews please can
you
present the report
thank you chairman
so this is um an application
um for a change of use of a rear surface
building to a residential
live stroke work unit and including
provision of secure
bike storage a bin straw and replacement
roofing tiles
in association with the shop at 119 high
street
um in malden so this side shows the
location of the
application site on on the high street
and this is a larger scale plan showing
the location
so the application site is that that's
edged in red
and the land edited in blue is
land also owned by the applicant and
then the
land edged in orange is a block of flats
to
the rear of the site the means of
vehicle access to the site is um part of
this green hatch area here
um and then you've got 119 high street
so there's the um
the building which you can just about
see there and there's a small courtyard
to the rear it's some
blown up version of the the drawing that
was shown and
that area edged in blue is in the
process of being
redeveloped for a single story um a
single dwelling
and um so this is the the building 119
with the courtyard air at the back and
this is where the
storage area for a bike and bins is
shown to be located
this is the existing ground floor plan
of the building
so the high street is at the top here
and with the
um what the shop floor floor area
and then at the back there's a store
which was associated with the shop
and a wet area where um there was a
preparation and
um of goods that was
sold in the shop and and elsewhere
with and there's an entrance lobby at
the back and then you can go up to a
flat
um upstairs
the proposed layout so it's a ground
floor the proposal affects the ground
floor only
so you've got the um the remaining um
shop floor area at the
top here which faces the high street um
and then to the rear you'd have the
lounge kitchen
unsweetened bedroom area created for the
the one bedroom flat
the entrance to the flat would be from
there from the rear and there would the
existing floor um through from the shop
to the to the rear area would be
closed and a wc and created in that
space
so 16 proposed west elevations so
this will be looking at um the property
from the courtyard of the rear
and very little change in terms of
external appearance
um although there would be improvements
in in terms of replacement
roof covering and new windows and doors
sympathetic to the listed building
this is a rear elevation again very
little
change
some photos um which the applicant
provided
showing this rear single story element
which would be
form part of the the flat and that would
be the
kitchen and the bedroom and then the
lounge area would be
within the two-story element of the
building here and this is the courtyard
um where the private administration
would provided a small amount there
and then you've got a photo at the front
of the high street showing the
shop that's there and a wider
um view of the stretch of shops that the
application site forms apart
so as as as referred to in the
description
and this is a resubmission of a previous
application which was refused for two
reasons
one being the potential harm to the
viability and vitality of the high
street
and due to the potential loss of the
existing class a1 use
because of how small the area was that
was remaining
so it was the shop and the associated
ancillary storage and preparation area
was 50 square meters and it's proposed
to be reduced to 23.6
square meters um and the other
reason for refusal was there was no off
street parking
provided for the occupiers of the the
new flat
um that remains the case
and the current application the the only
change is
the addition of a bike store and a bin
saw to the rear
in in in every other respect the
application is the same as that was
which was previously freed under under
delegated powers
so on that basis it's again recommended
for refusal
were basically the same reasons as um
the very similar application was refused
earlier this year thank you chairman
thank you mr matthews
in line with public participation scheme
i now invite the applicant
sam german to read out their submission
may i remind you that you are allocated
two minutes only for public speaking in
accordance with the scheme
mr german are you over there yeah hiya
you're at
okay yeah ready yes
what's that sorry if you can turn on
your camera please and
is it on isn't it um
yes it is on yes i can see you
yeah oh okay lovely thank you
right 119 high street had previously
been a fishmonger sat empty for over
four years in a dilapidated state
me and my girlfriend opened wolfenco
which the shop has had a fantastic
response
with the community in such testing times
and as you'll be aware there's obviously
many shops
that's been shutting down we've also
created free jobs within the community
for the
local people the building 119 was in two
halves
a small retail shop at the front divided
by a small opening of under 80
centimeters to the rear
the narrow entry is unaccessible for a
wheelchair and with such a small
corridor we're unable to keep an eye on
the shop at all times
[Music]
yeah the rear half actually was used for
a wholesale fish business not actually
part of the retail as
we said in our application in response
to the officers concerns with parking
uh we've got two public uh council owned
car parks in 30 seconds
walking the premises both offering
annual permits so it wouldn't be an
issue
i've got five recent applications uh on
malden high street which are very
similar
to our proposal small one bedroom
dwellings with no provision for car
parking
yet all being approved uh consent on the
basis that the local area is considered
sustainable
with good links to public transport and
i quote could be justified subject to
the provision of cycan store
which is what we have the conservation
officer has recommended approval and
states that the proposed works would
actually be a positive improvement
as you can see from some of the pictures
our proposed workload
unit would allow us to subsidize an
employee's wage against the rent
and help sustain a small business which
is unique to the high street
grant this application will secure our
future within
northern high street allowing us to stay
on there i've got i did attach
all five application numbers these are
all applications in the last two years
exactly the same
they've been um you know been granted so
uh yeah that's that's all i'll say thank
you mr charlemagne
recommendation is set out within the
report is as follows
the recommendation that planning
application 20 stroke
00796 full for 119 high street modern
essex be refused for the reason has
detailed
in section 8 of the report if any member
which is the second that motion please
turn on your video
unmute your microphone and state your
name now
thank you councillor stilts um i will
second that proposal
thank you i will now invite members to
make any comments on the report
berna has anyone indicated that it was
to speak
i think perhaps yes the uh wall
councillor councillor maize i think who
called it in
yes councillor lagan and then councillor
mays unless you want to take the ward
member first
yes thank you so cancer mays
thank you mr chairman i'm sorry my video
um
link won't allow me to put my camera on
at the moment i'm really sorry
um uh yeah i've got a couple of
questions
um the first one is regarding the car
parking space i'm a little confused
about this
um on the plans it shows that there's a
car parking space in blue
and then for 119 behind the building
um there's another car parking space
it's got car parking
space for 119 in yellow so it wasn't
wasn't quite clear on that
um there was also the element that um as
as mr
um jarman raised um that in the high
street there is
um i think that our spd actually states
that
if there is no um other means of
transport
then we'd have to provide something well
there is access to buses
there's also access to car parking um in
in two large car parks but lane and
i can't remember the other one off um my
secret car park as i call it
um so so that i'm not really very happy
about that
in the um report at 3.1.7
it says that the space is 30
square meters but i think miss matthews
said
it had been reduced to 26 square meters
again i wasn't quite sure on what
viability that had
um and whether or not there were minimum
spaces
that had to be allowed for bedrooms and
living spaces
um so is this unit too small and if so
by how much and why
um the third question i've got is
a lot of this work appears to possibly
have already been done so is this a
retrospective planning permission
question mark thank you mr chairman
thank you um it's matthews can you
answer those questions
um yes i'll try anyway thank you
um chairman um so there's reference to
the um let me share my screen again
the um
um two um parking spaces
in um blue and yellow and
orange um so on the screen there you can
see there's a
blue a car on the blue land but that
that's the parking space that was
approved for occupiers of the new
dwelling that is as i mentioned earlier
it's under under construction to the
rear of the site
that um parking space in the yellow or
in the orange area
is um understood to be
used by the occupier of the first floor
flat
um the existing virtual flat at 119 so
there is
no off street parking proposed for the
occupiers of the
the extra the new flat proposed
um there is there is public car
car parks in in the high street and
there is
a public um transport available for
for the occupiers of the flat but the
the um and there is provision
in the adopted parking standards
for um reductions potentially in in
sustainable locations where there is
alternatives to the use of the private
vehicle um
but there is a minimum requirement of
one space per
residential unit um even in high street
areas and and sustainable locations so
this this would be
if this were permitted this would be
contrary to the um
adopted policies and these have been
um these have been um
consistently um imposed
um that since the new standards were
adopted and that was in 2018
2017 2018 and the uh
applicant did make reference to
or did suggest that there were um five
previous permissions
where there was no parking approved as
part of a proposal
um they haven't i i haven't had a list
of
of those um previous plan permissions
but that there will be examples because
um
prior to the adoption of the new
standards um the
the parking standards were set as
maximums and not minimum so there would
have been
more of an opportunity for planning
permission to be granted with no parking
spaces
um and without being contributed to the
adopted pakistanis or the policies that
um
planning policies that are in use
um currently um there was also a
reference to
the permits being available in the
public park
the parking um car parks
um for residential occupiers to use but
and whilst they are available there's
been no suggestion by the applicant
that this is something that they would
do or something that they have applied
for
and so there's no guarantee that that
option would be um taken up
and even if it was accepted that that
would be an acceptable alternative to
on-site parking which is what the
standard
standards require in terms of floor
space
um in the report it
let me take my screen off now um in the
report it does
state that the ground floor
um of the building is um
50 extended 50 square meters and the
shop
area would would that would be reduced
to 23.6 square meters in terms of the
retail floor space that would be would
be left
um and i think the question
um was partly on about in um
minimum living spaces or um whether the
residential unit would be too small
that's that's not an issue or concern
that has been raised and
offices of view that the residential
unit proposed would be
of a sufficient size to provide adequate
quality of life for the
occupiers of the unit and the issue is
that this this
area um was used as part
um a part ancillary to the shop um
there was a wholesale element is
understood but the storage area and
there was a preparation area for the
shop
which um would be lost as part of this
application
um and in terms of a minimum size there
is no minimum size
um in policy um but
that area that's left now 23.6 square
meters
would be very small and and it may be
that the applicant
with sufficient information could
demonstrate that that shop would be
available
unit at that size but that process
hasn't been
gone through it was a reference to
another unit
um that was permitted further up the
high street which was smaller than 23.6
but that that um and again as is set out
in the report
um that unit wasn't a shop
to start with so that would it was that
was actually a bonus because the shop
was being created where the
retail shop was being created when there
wasn't one there um
already in terms of being whether this
application is retrospective or not
um it's that
it's not retrospective um in the
because there is a shop there now but
that was there was all
a shot there before so there hasn't been
a material change of use
the element of the rear the residential
element
um does not appear to have been occupied
and therefore there's no
that's not retrospective in that in that
respect and there has been some physical
works
changes to the building um
but um they are covered by the listed
building consent which has been
previously
granted for the actual physical works of
the building
um so there isn't um
so it's not retrospective in that
respect and certainly the use
the residential use does not appear to
have commenced and therefore the
application isn't retrospective in that
respect
um thank you i hope that answers the
questions if not come back and i can um
try again thank you angela mays is that
answered
yes um yeah mr chairman could i have
just one very small
supplementary um can you tell me what
um uh how the the car parking policy has
been
changed um as i i was working from the
2018 from the website
um and it's it it does say that um
if alternative means of transport
subject to a minimum provision of one
parking
car parking space for dwelling it this
can be
um lowered um and obviously
from one car parking space the only way
you can lower it is to
zero so i'm not i may be working from
the wrong
policy document and that'd be really
helpful to know thank you
through chairman it does sound as though
um handsome
is referring to the right policy
document um
it is a supplementary planning planning
guidance
document um but
i i think as as you've just read out the
minimum is
one space per per per um
residential unit and um that that
wouldn't be
provided here and i think that there is
as i said before there is
scope to reduce um australia parking
provision
within a high street area where there is
the opportunity to use other means of
transport
um but that that would only apply if for
example you had a
two or three bedroom unit and they were
only providing one space
you could argue in those circumstances
in some circumstances that
the one space would be sufficient having
taken having regard to
the alternative the public transport and
the sustainable location of the site and
access to services and facilities on
foot but there would still be them at
that minimum of one space
per unit and that wouldn't be complied
with here
or something else i was going to say but
um
i think that answers your your question
oh so so in terms of what's changed
um the uh i think as i said earlier
prior to 2018 the adopted standards
were set as maximums and not minimums
and there was no
comparable requirement that there was a
minimum of one space
per residential unit even in
high street or urban urban locations so
that has
been quite a big change um in terms of
the expectation of off street parking
provision
um compared to the policies that we had
um prior to 2018. thank you
thank you mr chairman thank you so
chairman can i just come in slightly on
that point as well
um just highlight that changing the spd
and the changing the
emphasis that malden district did in
2018 is reflective of changes within
government guidance between the two
documents being published
just a while ago the government's idea
was that
if you reduce the car parking down to no
car parking for a better phase it was
all about
maximum people would stop having cars
but
a lot of research and evidence has been
undertaken and that proves that isn't
actually accurate in most instances you
know people still want to retain
a car they'll need to storage of a car
even in large dwellings even when there
are other forms of sustainable transport
and facilities so government guidance
has changed
rather than it being maximum it went to
a minimum and as
captain said the our policy or lspd and
our policy obviously highlights that
reflects this current situation thank
you chairman
thank you thank you mr lee um
any other members who wish to speak yes
chairman we've got councillors lagan
heard
morris and councillor nunn would like to
make a point as well okay
councillor lagan
yeah thank you chair um i just i'm very
aware of the building i've known it
all my life um so the question for me is
is the actual shop frontage the sort of
retail space now
where the fish accounts used to be and
and the brilliant shop is there now
is that retail space does that stay the
same size or is that
room forget the room at the back and and
the wet fish storage and the store
behind
but that room that there's blue which is
the retail offer at the moment is that
is that going to stay
exactly the same size please
through chairman the um it is pretty
much the same size the only
um lost in floor area is the
small wc which would be um created in
the sort of the rear corner of it
and so in terms of retail retail it's
worth showing your camera
showing you're showing the plan okay
if we were committed in the traditional
room we'd have been able to uh just
would you
remember
okay yeah so um so the shop area
is um here and the um
the wc will be created in this this
corner here so
the the retail floor space where the
public would go
um would remain the same um
existing as well captains um
so the shop area here would be the same
um but what will be lost with this
storage and the
preparation and the ancillary space
which you would expect um a lot of
shops or most shops to need some sort of
storage or ancillary space
some back back um back office but
um some associated um space to support
the the retail floor space that they had
um so that's what would be lost here
rather than the
um the retail floor space where the
where the
customers would go thank you
thank you
matthews has covered it quite well and
obviously the officer of support does
but i think
that that's the primary concern that the
lpa has with it it's the loss of the
facilities rather than the specific
floor space you know a viable
commercial enterprise wouldn't you know
would need to have like travelers need
to have a store room
welfare facilities for the pro for the
employees etc and obviously
you know none of those facilities would
be able to be met with the
floor with the shop being changed to
just being solely
a retail area which is relatively small
and that's obviously where the council's
officer's
concerns relate to thank chairman thank
you absolutely
um counselor heard
yes thank you chairman um actually i
won't go over a lot of what
because some of the things have been
said but yes i
too am concerned about the loss of the
commercial business place because what
we'll end up with is just a
shop room without any
supporting areas to do that
i'm also concerned about the lack of
private immunity i mean they're talking
about
7.6 square meters
of of an area as
but it wouldn't be private and it
wouldn't meet
the minimum of 25 square meters
um i'm concerned also about the
car parking um because what happens with
deliveries
you know even if they don't have their
own vehicle which i suspect most people
would
where it where is it going to be kept
it's got to be kept off
street once you put
a dust bin in that 7.6 square meters
that makes it 6.6 square meters
and i'm really concerned about that also
the window outlook
which overlooks a service area which
doesn't really make it
an ideal living space
just because it's been done before or i
rece i realize that that's been quoted
but because it's been done before it
doesn't make it right
um and i don't think that we need to
take that into consideration
um i understand that uh there are that
the
amenity space is mitigated because there
are
um facilities within walking distance
but
of course you could you could go out the
front door and and find that but
i think as far as living premises are
concerned
i'm really uh cannot support this
i mean what would happen if the occupant
needed some kind of mobility vehicle
you know where would that be stored and
how would it be stored
i think what we've got here um is an an
outhouse supporting a commercial
business
um it's always meant to be an outhouse
and it's not really for me
a residential um
premise thank you chairman thank you
councillor heard
um i think councillor morris is next all
right
thank you chairman um and
congratulations on getting the chair
in your first uh role um
i was quite on the fence with this
application after reading the report
um i i've been persuaded now
by the uh applicant's representations
um i think it's important that we
support
retail in the high street um and our
residents
i believe that this application should
be approved
and if it fails um if the officer's
recommendation fails
i'd like to propose that we um approve
this application
uh there are no um complaintants that no
no one no one's got anything against it
no other neighbours or anything like
that
i think we should be helping our retail
um out in the high street and um
i'd like to propose that uh the
application is approved
thank you mr chairman i
would like to second that proposal as
and when it comes up
okay thank you councillors um
councillor london yes thank you very
much chairman
um i too am a bit troubled by this
parking
situation and the precedent that it
might create in terms of
other sites having said that i just want
to clarify a point my understanding
about the history of the site
is that the uh building that we're
looking at
was never separate retail um
it was used solely for preparation and
storage
which is peculiar to a fishmongers um
dog balls the fishmongers shop at the
front so
i you know to say it was a separate
retail unit or it's retail space
i think is a little bit misleading to be
honest with you
thank you very much chair thank you
councillor nun
berna is there anyone else who wishes to
speak the chairman caster swain has his
hand up oh thank you pardon
council swain yes sorry
sorry chapman i i haven't been able to
use
the chat function um yes if we're
talking about reducing
uh producing a shop of
these small dimensions i agree it isn't
really viable and very unattractive as
um self-standing premises
um i'm unless it were to be integrated
of course with the neighboring shop but
that's not on the agenda
um as far as parking is concerned um i
wonder if
um um ms matthews or mr lee can
um throw any light on how many
public parking places are taken up by
um residents um using them as
their own parking
don't have that information to hand
did you get that cancer finally sorry i
was gone
yes i i do yeah i
come back to the point i think that
counselor has made about um
having if we're having too many perhaps
amplifying his point
having too many places that rely upon
public parking spaces um i
perhaps
the officers one officer can say that we
have a policy on the use of public
parking spaces
for private purposes
in relation to um planning
obviously the policy requires on-site
car parking
um there is i suppose an acceptance that
there may be
a small percentage this may happen in
retail you know in commercial areas
where there is
access to public car parks but one of
the reasons our policy obviously
requires on-site car parking is so that
they aren't false for one of a better
phrase into using our public car parts
obviously you know if we built large
amounts of development in the town
center and we relied on the public
car parks see that would impact on the
retail of the uh
high street because obviously they'd be
full all the time with residents um so
you know obviously there's that issue
and obviously finance and that is a
separate matter for this which isn't
planning consideration
um i hope i've answered the question
council swain um in relation to
chairman for you if you don't mind
destroying to council and nuns point
earlier because i'm not quite sure if he
was
discussing with the point what the
council has said was in the lpa or
the applicant but for clarity the
council is highlighting that those areas
whether it's storage or wet
wet areas etc are ancillary currently to
the existing retail use
and if a different commercial enterprise
went in um whether it be
dressmakers you know
i saw a dress shop a candle shop
wherever obviously they would be the
storage so they would still have that
ancillary relationship
we aren't arguing it's a loss of a
commercial unit as in a unit it's not
going from what
two units to one unit through the
proposed application what we're saying
is that the
the current area of commercial
enterprise so that's both retail
frontage
including the retail area and the back
office
welfare facility sector will be shrunk
and that will have an impact on the
viability
of this one unit to be an ongoing viable
unit that they may fail i didn't know i
wasn't quite sure on council and
underpoints i didn't know if
members quite clean what officers were
saying so i just thought i'd clarify
that thank you chairman
thank you through through you chair um
i'm grateful to mr lee for clarifying
that point
thank you councilman councillor
schweiner your hand is up again is that
historical or
oh thank you and mr lee have you
something else to say your hand is up
sorry chairman that was the legacy oh
okay
okay um are there any more
members wishing to speak uh no chairman
councillor spain still has his hand up
as far as my screen is concerned but
apart from that no there are no more
um okay i think we can move to the vote
now
so berna would you please can you take
the vote
in our vehicle order yes so
we're actually um we're voting on the
officer's recommendation of refusal for
the reasons as detailed
in section 8 of the report members i
will take you
take your names in alphabetical order
can you please state clearly
for against our abstain counselor
miss a.m beale four
to refuse the application oh i'm sorry
i beg your pardon i'm four
yes i am for the refusal thank you
counselor lagan against praise burner
thank you councillor mays against
councilman morris
against that's the nun
uh reluctantly for
that's the show on the c four that's the
stilts
four
four
thank you members chairman that's seven
for the refusal
three against no abstentions thank you
bernard
that's then uh carried as a refusal then
thank you
and um thank you mr
dungate sorry thank you mr german
and thank you for your attendance you
will now be removed from the meeting and
may continue watching on youtube she so
wish to
thank you
item six twenty stroke zero zero
eight six two house and twenty zero
twenty zero zero eight six three lbc
seven
all saints london road we moved to
agenda item six
this planning application is found on
pages 27-38
please note that a member's update in
relation to this application has also
been circulated prior to the meeting
in a moment i will call on the officer
to present this item
members a reminder that if you wish to
speak on this item
please make this known by using the chat
function within this meeting
i will then come to you in turn please
keep your points clear
and succinct ms dungate please can you
present your report
yes thank you
planning permission and listed building
consent are sought for the construction
of a front extension at the application
property
which would incorporate an entrance area
cloakroom and snug
please note the members update which
includes the parish council response to
the application
um a consultation response has also been
received from cadent gas
highlighting that a low pressure gas
pipe is located within the vicinity of
the application
site if the committee are minded to
grant planning permission for the
proposal
it is recommended that an informative is
added to the decision notice to
highlight this
on the location plan you can see the
site outlined in red
which is located within the malden
conservation
the application property number seven is
located within the eastern
rear wing of the former allstate school
which is a grade two listed building
in 2017 an appeal was allowed to convert
the former school building into eight
residential units
which has now been implemented there is
a communal car parking area serving the
properties
located at the south of the site here
there is also a communal garden area
serving the properties
located in the south western corner of
the site here
this plan shows the positioning of the
proposed extension
on the eastern front elevation within
the front garden of number seven
you will also see the existing private
amenities space serving number seven
that would remain at the rear of the
property here within the central
courtyard area of the buildings
this is the existing ground floor plan
the proposed front extension would have
an l-shaped plan
so that the existing window within the
east elevation of the building is
retained
here
the existing elevations show the
rendered section
on the east front elevation of number
seven
which is considered to detract from the
original design of this part of the
building
the proposed elevations show the
proposal extending from part of the
rendered section of the front elevation
the extension would have a lean-to roof
and would have a brick detailing
and a rendered plinth that would match
the existing property
this 3d visualization shows the proposed
lean-to extension
in the context of the existing buildings
which would be a modest addition to the
property
this is a photo of the site from london
road where you can see number seven
here set back within the site
this is a photo um of number seven here
from the car park internally within the
site
this is a photo of the existing communal
garden serving the properties
located in the southwest corner of the
site
and this is a photo showing two existing
lean
two extensions on the corresponding
western wing of the former school
the proposal is considered to be
acceptable subject to the conditions
relating to external materials set out
in section 8 of the report
the council's heritage and conservation
specialist has raised
no objections to the proposal and has
commented that the proposal would result
in no harm to the significance of the
listed building and the conservation
area
it is therefore recommended that both
planning permission and listed building
consent
are granted for the proposed development
thank you chairman
thank you mr dungate
the recommendation that set out within
the report is as follows
a recommendation that planning
application 200862 has and 200863
lbc 7 awesome london road modern
sm968gb approved for the reasons
as detailed in section 8 of the report
if any member which is the second that
motion please turn on your video unmute
your microphone and state your name now
counselor
sorry um who was that who seconded it
was councillor bill but councillor heard
also seconded it
okay thank you um
and now invite members to make any
comments on the report if i go first
to the um ward member councillor maze
and call this in thank you um actually
uh counselor nun was before me and he
did
um on the chat so i give way to
counsellor nun oh thank you
sorry that's right
well um that's very good of you
councillor maze i'm happy for you to go
first but if you if you want me to
i will try no that's fine
no i'm quite happy um i suppose in many
ways i should have
declared an interest in this because i
used to go to school here
but uh um it's such a fantastic
building uh listed as you know and
built out of the bricks that were left
over from the construction of modern
east station
actually um but it's a special part of
our heritage and when i first saw this
application
i was really troubled by it because i
thought you know
the conversion was fantastic uh don't
mess with it
but actually i hold a lot of store by
tim howson
and his views as a conservation officer
as i do of course mr lee and his team as
well and
um when i looked at this i i agree that
it's not going to have a huge impact
it's not the frontage
and it's going to be in keeping by the
looks of it so
i i actually um i actually don't have a
major problem with this
thank you councillor none um councillor
maze i think yeah thank you
mr chairman um i've just got a couple of
questions
uh relating to the immunity space which
was obviously cut down from i think
25 square meters to now 12
um i don't know how amenity
shared amenity space plays into it but
what i was personally concerned
about the the amenity space attached to
this
um property uh which effectively will
become a three-bedroom
um dwelling uh although one year one
room is going to be used as a snug
um it can be seen from the road and i
personally think that it should be left
as it is
however i am going to listen to the rest
of the uh debate thank you
thank you councillor mayors um
councillor shaughnessy
i believe
thank you chairman um yes i know this
building very well as two of my children
um went to school here um
and as councillor none has said great
care was given
uh to the conversion to uh residential
units
and everyone in the area um you know
thinks that it looks very good
um and i realize that there are some
um parts of um what i think are possibly
the old school i'm not quite sure
that have have remained on that side of
the building that we're talking about
um which is proud of the main building
line
um but i think this proposal is
just a bit too big personally um
even though um tim hausen um agrees with
it and
and of course i too have great respect
for him
um but i would think that five meters by
three meters would be
far more in keeping along this
line um because if it were four meters
coming out it would be almost
to the gate or not very far from the
gate i went to look at it this afternoon
actually
um so i'm afraid i can't support the
application as it stands but i would
support
a smaller unit thank you
thank you councillor shawnee cancer
legend please
yeah thank you just to confirm i didn't
go to school there
but i also want to commit that make a
comment that um
tim hansen that he he's uh his views is
absolutely um priceless
um but i find myself drawn to the fact
that this
this development when it was done which
concerned me at the time was done
incredibly well and the building to me
is a very well balanced building
and i i can't draw myself to support
this because of the size
and very much like councillor shaunicy
and i think the the look
and the feel of the building would would
be um spoiled by adding on to this side
and because you know this one comes
through do the other facts then
look at it and uh decide that they want
something i know that's not a material
point but i just find myself troubled
with this um
and i i think as council shawn said it's
too big
and with sport with the development
thank you
thank you councillor um are there any
other members wishing to speak
uh no chairman not at the moment okay
um then please can we take we'll move to
the vote do you want me to come back on
the councillor
point on relation to immunity space yes
please
please thanks evan that's fine um
obviously
members will be aware of the office
report and it does
deal with the matter of um amenity space
and
the loss of it and this site is quite an
unusual one and as
members will discuss it's uh listed
building it's relatively recently
converted
um and i'm trying to remember obviously
the application was allowed to appeal
and that's explained in section 5.5.2 of
the offices of poll
and actually the council had raised
concerns around um
immunity space at that time but the
inspector found it to be
acceptable um
i think council amazes point is a fair
one
um obviously the provision of an
additional room
uh we can't always
the future use of it we have to take a
reasonable approach to
um you know easy way of looking at i
think and explain it you know
if someone's putting an additional room
at ground floor it's unlike if it's a
two-story house it's unlikely that'll be
use a bedroom but if they put on an
additional room at first floor it
slightly abuses a bedroom
even if not by the applicant by somebody
in the future so there needs to be a
reasonable approach to
understanding and considering the uses
and the
long term and you know obviously there
is a potential that this will increase
the bedrooms this site
but which is one consideration but also
though
i think it's the where the sighting is
and as um the officer's report
explains the current area it's proposed
is to the front and i think actually
inspectors did sort of give that some
merit but myself
personally or professionally i think
obviously there's very limited value in
private i mean it's patient it's not
private um and that's something that
generally most inspectors
agree with and most planners would stay
and it's only you know
i think it was a little bit surprising
when the last appeal decision was made
but
generally i think officers think
consider that where the sighting of this
is it wouldn't
detract from the level of private
immunity space for the site for the
occupiers and
as always with these things they're
subjective or not always but at this
point it's subjective
and obviously that's within members give
but i think i should highlight what
officers report says in relation to that
thank you chairman thank you thank you
mr lee
thank you sorry um
um we'll move to the vote then so berna
please can you take a
a vote please rolling
uh thank you chairman members um we're
voting on
the officer's recommendation to approve
uh the application
um seconded by council reveal i will
i'll take your names in alphabetical
order can you state clearly
for against or abstain counselor miss
beale
four edwards
four that's the head
four
again space tara thank you it's berna
casa mays against
castle morris four
[Music]
against you councillor swain
paul members
chairman that's six for the application
for against and no abstentions thank you
bernard
that's carried then as as as approval
thank you
thank you uh item
seven agenda item seven twenty stroke
zero one zero one zero has 98 washington
road modern cm96ar
we moved to this agenda item which you
found on pages 39-54
please note that a member's update in
relation to this application
has also been circulated prior to the
meeting
in a moment i will call on the officer
to present this item
members a reminder that if you wish to
speak on this item please make this
known by using the chat function
within this meeting i will then come to
you in turn
please keep your points clear and
succeed ms martin please can you
present your report please
thank you chair
sorry one moment
planning permission is sought for a
single story front extension
an increase in height to the western
side elevation alterations to the root
performance of an existing rear
extension
a flat roof dormer to the rear and
additional windows and roof lights
the application site is situated to the
northern side of washington road
the site consists of a two-story
detached dwelling with projections to
the front and rear elevations
the surrounding area is residential in
nature with dwellings of similar design
and scale
here is the block plan it should be
noted that extent permission
exists on the site whilst the
application is different to that
approved previously
it is similar in nature the cross
hatching and red outline to the front
shows the extent the footprint of the
extent permission
here are the proposed floor plans
the proposed second floor plans
here are the proposed front and rear
elevations
here are the proposed side elevations
as mentioned extant permission exists at
the site for a development similar in
nature
the members clarity have provided
comparisons of the extent permission
against plans of the current application
the eastern front extension has been
removed from the proposal
and the remaining front extension and
porch is of the same scale as the extent
permission
the extension to the rear has the same
footprint as the extent permission with
two additional roof lights proposed
here are the plans showing the
comparisons of the first floor of the
extant permission
against the current application
here are the plans showing the
comparisons of the second floor of the
extent permission
against the current application noting
the roof lights and windows
here are the plans of the front and rear
elevations of the extent permission
against the current application to the
front a roof light has been added
this has been completed as well as an
increase in ridge height to the western
projection
these elements are retrospective in
nature
the windows at second story have been
removed as well as the eastern front
extension
to the rear the changing roof form of
the rear extension has been completed
and is retrospective in nature
the addition of roof lights are proposed
the second story window has been removed
and a dormer window is proposed
here are the plans of the western and
eastern side elevations
on the western elevation the gable
window has been added in his
retrospective in nature
with roof lights proposed a door has
also been removed from the proposal
to the eastern elevation three
additional roof lights are proposed
a side window has also been added to the
side elevation of the rear extension
here are some photographs of the site
which show the completed elements of the
proposal
these photographs show views from inside
the property from the second floor
window and rear extension
this is a view of the street scene at
first floor level
it is considered that the development
due to its scale and design
on balance would not harm the character
and appearance of the host dwelling or
locality
whilst there are limited views of the
neighboring immunity space to the rear
it is not considered the degree of
overlooking would cause demonstrable
harm to the immunity of these
neighboring occupiers to warrant a
reason for refusal
particularly when considering the extent
permission at the application
site in addition it is not considered
that the development detrimentally
impacts on car parking provisions
or private community space at the site
and therefore the development is in
accordance with policies
d1 h4 and t2 of the local development
plan
and is recommended for approval thank
you
thank you miss martin in line with the
public partition
participation scheme we have received
two submissions
i now invite an objector and then giles
to read out his submission may i remind
you
that you have allocated two minutes only
for public speeding in accordance with
the scheme
thank you mr charles can you
yeah can you see me yes
okay good evening thank you for the
opportunity to speak on behalf of
numerous residents
as you are aware this issue has been
going on for over four years
and was rejected consistently by this
committee
i cannot respond to the large number of
disputed points in the planning office
report in two minutes
but i can respectfully draw your
attention to some of the inaccuracies
firstly this retrospective application
does not include the increased roof
height
the planning notice though was amended
to include it
the report states it to be minimal but a
fifty percent
increase that's five zero is not minimal
neither does it concur with the approval
eventually given by the secretary of
state in their report
the ndc planning report goes on to
discuss privacy issues relating to some
of the 14
additional windows but completely emits
the very large third story windows
which are the major concern to the
residents equally
the report proposes obscured glass in
windows which according to the submitted
plans
won't exist it is clear that there is a
significant degree of confusion between
the numerous plans and reports that
exist around this application
creating an unacceptable level of
uncertainty as to what is being approved
there are further concerns relating to
the eventual creation of a five to six
bedroom
three-storey property with inadequate
parking which is out of keeping with the
rest of the neighborhood
we would like to propose that the
committee request that the report is
rewritten
checked and then confirmed with a site
visit to ensure that all reports
applications plans and drawings match
the situation
and provide a definitive set we would
request that the revised report be made
available to residents with sufficient
time for us to make appropriate written
representation the residents are able to
provide you with a
report detailing all of the issues and
inaccuracies we have identified so far
with the report
if the chairman would provide us with
that facility
thank you from the residence in
washington road marklin drive
and norfolk road thank you mr charles
sorry apologies chairman before we
continue can i check if counselor mays
and counselor morris are still in the
meeting i know councillor morris had
some internet problems
his customer service yes lovely thank
you very much
okay thank you chairman i think
councillor morris has actually
dropped out of the meeting entirely at
this point
thank you thank you um and i invite the
applicant
karen wiseman to read out her submission
may i remind you that you're advocating
two minutes only for public speaking
speaking in accordance with the scheme
that's what
wiseman are you there i am indeed can
you see me
oh sideways i apologize i'm on a
i'm on a ipad so yeah you'll just have
to do this
thank you okay good evening councillors
the planning inspectorate granted
original planning permission on appeal
the inspector report had already
addressed and discounted
the regurgitated objections received on
this application
the pitched roof together with the
raised ridge height would be more in
keeping with the neighbourhood neighbor
neighbouring street scene
the lounge extension has been removed
the front addition
is limited in depth and the appearance
of the garage in height and roof form
would mirror that of number 100. whilst
properties in this part of washington
road share some similar features
there is no overall uniformity of design
and appearance
and the proposals would therefore not
dominate the host dwelling
nor would they be visually incongruous
within the locality as has been
suggested
the appeal officer concluded that there
was no evidence to suggest that the
proposed extensions
would result in harmful addition on to
on-street parking
and that the council was and still is
satisfied that the number of parking
spaces will meet the appropriate
standards
while higher level windows have been
removed from the original plans and
velux windows added
the first floor windows already face
each other and any existing gardens and
out buildings
from the photographs you can clearly see
there is no loss of privacy to either
neighboring property
there is also no evidence to suggest
that by creating an additional bedroom
this would increase occupancy of the
host dwelling most of the objectors are
of two-person occupancy
and living four-bedroom houses is the
same logic to be applied
finally the original planning
application was not
refused on any planning argument
moreover the fears expressed by local
residents who appear not to have
understood the proposals in detail
or sought to seek clarification but
instead have chosen to base their
arguments on fear
provoked by a few in the neighborhood
this is demonstrated by objections
received from properties that are some
distance from the host dwelling
i therefore urge you not to put our
family yet again
through a needless and costly appeal
process but to allow us
to allow us to simply put our home back
together
thank you mr wiseman thank you
the recommendation is set out within the
report is as follows
the recommendation that planning
application 20 stroke
zero one zero one zero has the 98
washington road modern
cm96ar approved for the reasons as
detailed in section 8 of the report
if any member wishes to second that
motion please turn on your video
unmove your microphone and start your
name
i will second that thank you
i will not invite members to make any
comments on the report i see mr lee
wanted got his camera on did you
no he's muted chairman i think he's just
you're muted
okay um so we start with councillor herd
i believe who wants to make
a declaration and ask a question oh
sorry yes
cancer hurt
um thank you chairman i just wanted to
make it clear i'm not sure i did it in
my original declaration
that i had a non-pecuniary interest
in this item in that i have had a
telephone conversation
with an objection with an objector
however
at no time did i express a view one way
or another
um i'm very hap i know that councillor
shaughnessy would uh wish to speak and
i'll give way to her as we're both board
members
thank you councillor councillor shawnee
yes thank you chairman um likewise with
um
counselor heard i have had um various
people
emailing me but i have just um answered
politely
and have not given um any indication
um as to pre-determination on any of
this
so i would just like to make that
statement thank you chairman
um i understand that the uh proposed um
gary garage extension toward towards the
road
i think it's of two meters was
apparently allowed on appeal
um but i think that this
um probably will add to the parking
issues
and we have discussed parking issues um
earlier
this evening um i know i i have a
feeling it will add to those
um the front fan light
on the front of the building or on at
the top
um has direct line of sight
the bedroom of 121 washington road
was this allowed by appeal
from the exp inspector please i would
like to know that
the new extended part of the roof
does this comply with height
the height that was passed on appeal um
the um the inspector stated at appeal
that the height that he passed um was in
line
with the neighbors number 100
i believe i would like that clarified
please or if
this has since been breached
um lots lots of people are worried about
the
lowering of the back garden at 98. um
seems to be an issue about runoff um i'd
like to know about that please
um and the planning department
previously to the appeal
did reject it on over-development
there is a concern in general about the
number of windows
and i think a definitive number there i
think really probably needs
um going over again so that everybody
understands thank you
um and and how many that are to be
um locked um and or obscured
please um and i'd like to know if
officers have visited this site at any
time
please um the breach of covenants
is worrying i don't i realize that it's
it's not a planning issue but
it is certainly worrying um that the
builders
of various builders have not complied um
with them um i don't think that
this is a very good design and does not
enhance the
area um referring
um to planning um d1
and the windows
do the windows in the application con
conform
with the windows that were passed at
appeal
i'm really not sure about this and it
and
and if not could these possibly be
added at a later date the ones that were
passed at appeal
um so i have several concerns there i
hope
that relevant uh planning officers
please
have noted those and i too have
a note about a site visit i think this
is quite a complicated issue
um and and i think
we need to ensure a bit more clarity
here
um so therefore i am asking for a site
visit
um i'm i realize that we are in a covert
situation
but i do think that could be managed
um indeed the lady who owns the house
did invite me
to look over the house but i couldn't
um at the time because it would have
been unethical of me to do so by myself
it only has to be
it must only be in the presence of an
officer
um and are there ever kind of two site
visits
bearing in mind the covid situation um
and obviously
no more than two people could go into
the um
premises or on the premises at any one
time i do realize this
so um some answers please thank you
thank you uh uh councillor shauna c um
well quite a number of questions there
um
uh mr lee you've come up i did you want
to
cancel i'll pick up a few of the points
i think uh ms marden can pick up a
couple of others near to the end if
she's happy to support myself
um i think the first point to remember
is members is that there is a planning
application that has been granted for a
very similar form of development on site
um the fact that that fallback position
that went through appeal
isn't it does exist it has to be the
starting point for any determination of
this application
you know as the officer's report
explains there's no real issues in
relation to
car parking etc compared to what was
granted
um at appeal look trying to raise
concerns that have already been
investigated by an inspector and found
to be the
non-reason's refusal would be a very
dangerous approach to take
as a council the starting point does
need to be development plan
unless material situations indicate
otherwise which is always the case
and a planning history particularly when
it was either an approval at appeal or
even approval anyway
what is still live that still could be
implemented as in it has started so it
will always remain an extent in this
case
would be a very very important point and
that is really what members need to be
looking
at is to certainly is not what the house
was like originally compared to what
they're submitting for
um what are the differences between
approved and what has been
started to be built and what they are
looking to complete that is the big
difference um
in relation to the point about windows
obviously the current application
is what it is if you want it for better
phrase they would be able to
complete that if granted plan admission
and that would show the windows that
are on those plans um
they wouldn't then be able to implement
the other permission so any additional
windows wouldn't be able to be put in
because
that would be the other permission they
can't have both um the fact that
actually they could probably do a lot of
the works under committed development is
a separate point and additional windows
for example don't
normally require plan information
because they are deemed to be
acceptable in the eyes of the government
without needing requirements to plan
permission sometimes they need to be
obscure glazed
sometimes they don't depend on the
specific dynamics of it
my understanding is that the we have
done a site visit for this
application um whilst there have been
some
comments around a change of levels um
there isn't any evidence the council has
of that but notwithstanding that runoff
generally isn't a planning
issue in a small scale sort of
development such as this um
to be honest actually it's a civil issue
and if it comes under trespass but
that's a separate matter but it wouldn't
normally be
a mata so for example if you build an
extension on your house and your
duck or your drain or your
the guttering oh goes over to your
neighbor and it drains into that
property that isn't actually a planning
matter that wouldn't be a reason for
reviews or something that we look at
and that also very much goes for the
points on covenants
covenant is civil legislation that
cannot be material consideration
determination of any planning
application
the fact that for example it's a
covenant building
etc environment health if it does if it
falls valve another form of legislation
another council department or anything
like that
that is not a conversation for the
committee us
today or decision makers therefore we
only look at planning matters
and case law is clear we can only look
at the matters that relate to planning
so anything that
isn't within our remit we need to be
silent on it's um
unfortunately planning doesn't worry
about personal issues so those matters
aren't planet we just have to park no
matter
how any sympathetic you may feel or
value you may think they have
um but i think that sort of generally
brought up most the questions but
i don't know if any accounts i don't
know if
sorry i'm not sure i can't think if
there was any i think so madam you
there's a couple you're going to pick up
and i said wasn't there no then if we
can see if that's then answered all of
cancer's
counsellors seances up questions thank
you chairman
thank you yeah through your chair i
believe
matthew probably answered everything
that i was going to
speak about um the as we were talking
about the roof flight to the front
um is in the remit of permitted
development anyway
the ridge height has only been raised
0.65 meters from that approved
and that's that's what we're looking at
the difference from that approved to
what is what they're applying for now
thank you so much um i have to disagree
i think 0.65 meters
is quite a lot to for a ridge height
to be um raised um further to the one
approved on appeal
um and as the one um discussed
uh within the appeal um was in line with
the
house next door then this it stands to
reason
that it now doesn't um fall in line with
the one next door
so i find that quite concerning actually
thank you
thank you councillor showing to see
thank you i
just come back on something else i've
just remembered the uh point on the
uh site visit what
obviously this is we are under difficult
and challenging times at the moment but
taking into account the normal position
all members that would have to attend
the site visit at the same time
because it's a formal part of the
committee so if the committee defers an
item for a site visit he's a formal part
of the committee so
any all members that were to vote would
have to be all fully aware of all the
points that were made so you'd all have
to be there together to hear any
points that were made or discussed to be
able to then be fully informed at the
time of the uh
committee decision that would be my
understanding that is to certainly send
a guesstimation based on
the old world obviously we are in
challenging times but i'm just trying to
think about the
point of law on that but
uh if i may chairman through you
chairman perhaps this is something to be
discussed
then mr lee to um you know facilitate
this
maybe not now i mean but um you know
at a different time possibly
thank you councillor thank you thank you
uh councillor swain i think he's next
no counselor heard would like to come
back and ask a question
then councillor mays and then councillor
swain chairman
right thank you
thank you chairman uh could i ask miss
martin if we could have the
um proposed and uh current development
back on screen please
yes of course no problem
apologies
okay would you like the elevations more
over the floor plans
i think it's the uh the picture of the
house there
uh yes that's uh yeah that's fine thank
you very much
um well my point is going to be one
on scale and design and i know that that
this
is subjective however
i do find this application is contrived
imbalance and i believe that it is
incongruous
um what i find quite astounding is uh
that the very top window on the
left-hand side
the front elevation as as amended
i i find it rather unbelievable
that you can have this window even if it
is even if it is frosted over
um it still will look directly down
into the houses opposite um and if i
were living there
i'm afraid i wouldn't be very happy and
i do find this is an invasion of the
privacy
of the neighbours um also i'm rather
concerned that with the additional
living space
being taken up from the front that there
will be
once again a loss of parking uh
this house is right on the jaws of the
junction
of um markland
communist avenue or drive driver i think
right in the very jaws of that um and i
think that that
that is creating a dangerous um
precedent but to
to me my objections for this uh would be
the imbalance
and uh the the fact that it would be an
incongruous
building um i don't like the angles
um i certainly wasn't aware of the
number of objectives
and i wasn't aware of that until we had
the first speaker
but once again i would certainly say uh
that we should have a
um a site visit if this were destined
for
um approval but uh i'm afraid i can't
support it thank you chairman
thank you councillor hood uh
thank you mr chairman um i've just got a
couple of
um questions on the
uh plans that you referred to velux
windows
are these opening deluxe windows and if
so how far
um i personally don't have a problem
with them
and um am i writing reading these
these correctly that on the existing
front elevation which is the one on the
left that there should have been
instead of a a double window in the
gable end
that's now been effectively moved to
a roof a roof light or a an opening
i don't know whether it's an opening or
a fixed roof light
on the roof um they were the only two
questions i had because
councillor uh shawnee had covered
everything else thank you
thank you
mrs marvin can you answer that both
questions
uh yes so um
um the uh second story windows have been
removed
from this um elevation
um and instead there is a
side gable window and then the dormer
window
uh to the rear whereas this had um a
second floor story window here sorry was
there any was there something else
um were the deluxe windows opening the
velux windows or are they fixed closed
windows
i i don't have the answer to that
actually because some deluxe windows are
actually
literally for light which is different
to if they are opening
which um if you've ever tried to hang
out of a velux window it's actually
quite difficult
just to put it out there um and they're
all they're all the rage in cambridge
even in the uh conservation area so
um yeah i don't necessarily thank you
thank you
thank you what i can't tell you is this
this window
uh on this elevation is going to be
opaque glazed and non-opening and we
would
consider conditioning in these to be
opaque glazed as well
i think okay thank you okay thank you
thank you
um council swain i believe
thank you gentlemen um yes i don't think
what i mean these increasing number of
windows in the um um third story
um i think one has to link it to the
fact that the ridge height has been
increased
and my mind that makes
in combination that has turned what
would be a roof space
attic storage area or whatever into
potential living space
and i don't see how that fits with the
um um the um
the planner's idea of numbers of rooms
and so on and i do think they
they um are um overlooking
i can't can't get away from the fact
this is going to be a three-story
residential building um in an area where
um it's essentially a true story
thank you councillor three um i don't
think there's a question there was there
uh yes um doesn't um
do not the planning officers have a view
on the fact that this is effectively
enabling
the increase in substantial increase in
living space
or bedroom space for the property okay
um miss marvin can you answer that
yes sir one moment sorry i'll just get
the floor plans back up
so there is an increase in um living
space and we're not disputing that
um there's i think there's three four
bedrooms
on the second floor an additional
bedroom
on the third floor or second floor sorry
um but with regards to private immunity
their garden area is big enough and
the amount of car parking provisions is
adequate for the number of rooms on the
site
ms martin can you just show the
elevations the yeah approved and
uh what they're submitting that'd be
helpful
sorry i think uh just to pick up on the
point
um obviously the roof of the
is has been raised as we've discussed
but you can see it doesn't actually
reach the point of the highest pitch of
the roof at the moment and it so it is
set down
and so what members need to look at is
that is that
change between those two roof lines
so injurious to the street scene and
does it create such
incongruous an alien feature that it
would appear out of place when compared
to what
could be built lawfully um officers
consider that the
short the small change in the short
shorter roof does still result in a
relatively subservient form of
development
that when compared between the two
wouldn't appear particularly out of
place in relation to
councillor swain's point personally and
this is only my personal opinion
the actual removal of the windows
at the front within what would have been
the you know the roof space
actually makes it less of an obvious
feature within the street scene by the
vision of a
fairlux window in the um
within the roof slope so i think that
obviously those differences so there's a
slight increase in height obviously
there's a removable that window
and personally this is just my personal
opinion i think actually would lessen it
but
this is a subjective point but members
if they're looking to
i think this is really a very good
picture to look at members actually see
these are the differences and what is
the harm between
what was approved and what is now being
submitted it's not a case of what is on
site at the moment what's on site and
what they submitted
it's about comparing the two schemes and
seeing really
what democracy fatal from these two
schemes thank you chairman
thank you mr league um i think
come to have quick points on the
comeback yes
when you look at the the um
the drawings um the
increase in the roof height is um
slightly
an illusion because the whole drawing if
it's the same
scale is it the same scale
it's magnified isn't it actually it's
larger than the
we've had to yeah we've had to obviously
cut them out of uh
plans here they aren't identical this is
just for guide but you can see that the
distance is a little bit less between
the two
the other point is how does this compare
with the
roof the room space and number of
bedrooms of the original building
in washington road
in other words were these all really
originally designed to be three bedroom
houses
um um through it's a bit of a difficult
off the cuff i don't have the answer um
to a certain extent it's a moot point um
the point members need to consider is
the proposed development and does it
meet
our policy requirements so that would be
design community space car parking
impacts on neighbours etc
there is an envelope of development that
all sites can take it varies
very much between site by site it can be
constrained by multiple different points
it could be design if you're in an area
of a ridiculously strong
uniform character you may find that
actually there's almost no development
that can be had
it could be pulled due to limited
amenities space that could restrict
additional development so it's not a
case of what was on site
comparing it to what they're proposing
per se what's importance is what they're
proposing and
can the quantum of development be
accommodated within the application site
so as i said like as mrs martin said you
know is it a four-bedroom property but
it meets the
policy requirements in everything i
think like
for example amenity space um obviously
there's the issue of
overlooking but officers don't think
take into account potential for
conditioning
what's already on what was proposed et
cetera that there was any demonstrable
harm in that matter either
thank you chairman well chairman if the
um
increase in the height and the roof
lights and so on
make the top um story
um quite suitable for additional bedroom
or bedrooms does that have an impact on
the view of the burners in relation to
parking spaces
um mr lee can you come back on that
answer
just obviously that will be in the
office's report and i was just trying to
as always i like to um take members to
the section within the report and
it looks like i've unfortunately just
scrolled and ended up with one of the
other items
some if you just give me a moment i'll
look it up i don't know if any other
members have got any points or comments
they could do that well i'll just
quickly look that up
counselor shaunicy had some had another
question while
mr lee is finding that oh can't you
honestly yes
sorry all right thank you bernie thank
you chairman
um it's a pity that the diagram has gone
off my screen but because i think it's
quite obvious why
the roof heights in those two um
sets of diagrams are different because
one is one that was
allowed at appeal and the second one is
is the one that has that has been built
which is one of my first points when i
was speaking earlier
and i think that it looks much more in
keeping
with the um the elevation as approved at
appeal
but not the one as amended thank you
and um and i and i definitely think that
we should not make a decision on this
tonight but we should have a side visit
thank you so much thank you council i
think
uh councillor none wanted to come in
yes yes thank you very much chair i've
listened really carefully to
everything that's been said and i know
that you know the the issue here about
sort of what was approved on appeal
but it's a kind of general question for
mr leon
i apologize to mr lee in advance if this
sounds a bit sort of ignorant on my part
but
is there no kind of ongoing inspection
of development as it as it takes place
because what worries me about this is
the retrospective nature of the
of of the consideration is there no
inspection
as the building's going up to see if it
complies with
what was actually approved uh thank you
chair
thank you chairman um i don't
you know
the quick answer is no um we you know
there is we don't have compliance
officers within the authority i know
some authorities do but none that i've
ever worked
and none that i know of around this area
at all
um that obviously is a quite an
intensive and resource-hungry
process to go through and the authority
doesn't have the resources to do that
so we do rely on if breaches are
happening we rely heavily on the public
general public race and then obviously
officers do know things at times as well
when we run out on site members
such as yourselves obviously highlight
things to us that's the crucial part of
the
planning process i don't think anyone
ever is comfortable when they see the
word retrospective app on an application
and i know it does sometimes
call some level of offense whatever
better phrase but to a certain extent
that is a silent matter
we still need to look at whether or not
there is
any harm from the development whether
it's retrospective or not um
that is the situation you know
unfortunately for whatever reason
what often applications coming after
it's
been commenced applications like this
where the scheme
meanders and slightly alters during the
process and that is something that
we do have to deal with as the decision
makers uh thank you chairman
oh vote chairman also i've looked up the
point
um and it's dealt with the novices
reporting
um the current proposal is three
bedrooms and
four bedrooms but three car parking
spaces like the previous one
which is policy compliant so
it the increasing cut i mean arguably
the increase in uh
car parking so the increase in bedrooms
hasn't resulted in any increase in car
parking requirement
but also as explained in 5.4 5.4.3 the
current application has admitted a
section
of the front extension resulting in an
additional 5.4
squared meters of hard standing so the
actual level of hard standing
well obviously that space alone wouldn't
accommodate a car park a car
parking space alone there is a little
bit more hard standing to the front
and the car parking provision is policy
compliant thank you chairman
thank you mr lee check chair could i
just come back on
that please with your permission
chair yes yes thank you very much yes um
thank you mr lee i used to be reminded
constantly by a previous councillor that
uh
retrospective applications were
acceptable
uh but it doesn't sit comfortably with
me i'm afraid
um but can you tell me then mr lee did
did you you or your department receive
any alerts
uh from residents uh whilst the building
work was taking place
do you chairman my understanding is this
application was submitted on the back of
a
enforcement investigation thank you
okay um i'm grateful chair and i'm
grateful to mr lee i didn't know that
honestly um so that's um that clarifies
that
position thank you very much thank you
councilman
um cancer saunacy i think again
castle shouldn't say you're muted
i do beg your pardon thank you um
yes i'd just like to reiterate uh i
think mr lee was looking up something
else whilst i was um
talking before um i just will reiterate
that the difference between the two
diagrams is the
um as it says elevation is approved at
appeal
and then the elevation as amended um and
i would just like to state again
um as i did right at the beginning of um
of this
item that um
the um inspector on appeal
um approved the roof
height as is on the left in the diagrams
because it was level with the next store
roof and of course now it isn't
and we do have to have you know a form
of
of you know sort of consistency
um with these roof levels and we've had
this time and time again at planning
um and it is and it is something that we
always take notice of
um and and also um you know it's it's
not
above um we're we're not above
um having things put right if they are
indeed wrong um after the uh a proper
decision was made at appeal thank you
thank you council shawnee um
but rather any more members want to
speak
chairman cancer swain would like to make
a proposal he's possible in the meeting
chat but obviously it needs to be
proposed within the meeting itself
all right okay thank you very
consciously
um yes um um referring partly back to
what counselor heard
um said and i seems to me that the
large number of windows in this is is a
a problem from a design point of view so
i was
considering or suggesting that we could
reject the
um the application um
because of this proliferation of windows
affecting the design and appearance of
the building
uh thank you council
we already have a proposal of course on
the table from the officers which needs
to be
voted on uh do we need to have a second
on council swain's uh proposal first or
can we
if we deal with the press sorry
you have to deal with the current
proposal first yes okay
um
i've just been looking up the appeal
decision for the previous application
and
uh i can't see the any text along the
lines of what
council shawnee noted in relation to why
the inspector said it was acceptable
in that point um so
my bit is jumping out to me it says
while properties in this part of
washington road share some similar
features
there is no overall ufo uniformity in
design and appearance
consequently the limited extensions
proposed would not appear in congress
and uncharacteristic in the
residential setting the appearance of
the garage in terms of height and roof
form would mirror that of the
neighbouring property number 100 albeit
would project further forward
seeing from views approaching on either
side the full projection of the garage
and lounge would
have a limited effect in the obscuring
views of the proposed property
properties either side
this would be mitigated in part by the
staggered building line but in any case
it would book views from properties
overall and would not therefore lead to
material
harm in the street soon so i'm just
trying to find bits of the island
obviously
give members some advice on the point
that was being raised i'm able to find
any clarity on there and sorry sharon
thank you
thank you can i ask a question regarding
uh councillor shaunic's
proposal for a site visit although i
understand the difficulty on that
through you chairman um personally
i'm not i don't consider that you know
that this application
really needs a service i think you know
taking into account the changes there
well there might be a lot of numbers
when you look at it on
paper and the actual overall variances
between the two developments is quite
minimal
um you know councilman mays raised some
issues in relation to the velux and as
ms martin said if members want we can
condition that they're fixed shuts and
obviously certainly
obscure glazed um but i don't really see
what benefits the scheme would get from
uh a site visit but obviously that as
always is in with the members gift but
as always you need to take the record
the prevailing
uh position first for the committee i
think yeah
yes thank you that's it council shawna
said you want to come back thank you
chairman yes it's very kind of you
um i i think as a site visit is needed
um because
also um there is concern about
what the garage at the moment is used
for
i believe and if a car cannot be put in
there
then that cuts down on a parking space
thank you thank you
thank you the german obviously the
clarity
what it's been used for at the moment
wouldn't necessarily be a mature
consideration the termination of
this application um we would obviously
need to ensure that car parking is
provided on site at a level that is
necessary
um i'm just quickly trying to review the
conditions that are being put forward um
okay yeah it doesn't actually look like
there is um so there isn't actually a
condition
i'm too sick so i go to the appeal
decision
so actually um
all right let's have a quick sorry
depending on how they've laid it out
what are the conditions on condition
three mr lee it does say
that uh the windows will fitted obscure
glazing
and right through your channel what i
was getting at is that actually
the conditions imposed by the plan
inspector
nothing requires that that garage to be
to be retained as a cut for car parking
so if they were to build out the
authorised development they could
convert the garage into a
bedroom if they wanted the next day
without needing planning permission
so and as i said even what's being used
for now would be a silent point
if members considered the fact that it's
now going to a four bedroom
meant that the car parking was more of a
larger concern
it wouldn't be unreasonable to impose a
condition in relation to car parking if
they so wish to be retained including
the garage
that is what it's shown on the plans but
i've the fact that what it's been useful
today at this moment when it's uh when
it's not complete development isn't
really a material consideration
thanks chairman okay thank you
um berna is there anyone else
and on the border point of order from
yes cancer swain has a point of order
yeah can't just wait
sorry chairman but we come to this
question about having a motion on the
table
um and um the point is
um
my my motion would only be discussed
if the um substantive one that is to say
the officer's recommendation
but what is the point of that if people
don't think
that my reason on design is sufficient
reason
to reject it in other words there have
to be other reasons for rejecting it
other than the one
in my motion which won't have been
discussed at that stage
um
well yes i mean the motion has been
raised in the first
instance and that has to be disposed of
before we can have a second motion
um if in the event that that motion
if in the event uh this is
refused then we can go forward with
another motion
thank you thank you none i agree with
councillor heard that
it's very clear that there's a motion on
the table which has got to be voted on
and if that fails then we would consider
other issues
let's not confuse things please thank
you councillor none
okay i think we debated this now quite
substantially so
uh we'll now move to the vote and
bernard please can i have
can you take the vote thank you members
we are voting for the office's
recommendation of approval for the
reasons as detailed in section 8 of the
report
and this was julie seconded by
councillor mays if i remember correctly
um members please note i will not be
calling a counselor morris to vote
because unfortunately he lost
connectivity for
approximately 31 minutes and he actually
noted that in the meeting chat
thank you very much members i will take
your names in alphabetical order
can you please stay clearly for against
or abstain
starting with councillor miss beale
against
edwards before
prepared against
councillor lagan
against please thank you
councillor mays for
the nun against
cancer shaughnessy against again
stilts
poor thank you cancer swain uh okay
thank you thank you members chairman
that's
three for the application six against
no abstentions thank you okay thank you
um council heard uh in that case
chairman i'd like to make a another
another uh proposal
uh that this is that this is refused
uh on the scale and design
in that it is a contrived
and incongruous appearance which is
resulting
in an overbearing aspect which is out of
character
for the area
thanks thank you councillor head uh
cancer um
mr lee is that um do you chairman um
mrs martin is possible to call up those
elevations again
thank you um teacher and obviously as i
said you know members need to
consider the difference between those
two is really what we're talking about
um and personally i consider
that reason for fusion probably
overplays the variances in design terms
between the
two proposals um i think
um obviously it's a subjective matter
it's in the
gift of the members to come to decision
they see fit but
you know i think when you can see on the
left hand side of the screen what was
approved at appeal and then on the
right hand side the differences i think
you know i'm not sure you could say it
would be particularly incongruous
when comparing the two together but as
always that's within the members gift
thank you chairman
thank you so
um if i may i i'm i i think that uh
i would be quite happy to change that to
imbalance
uh because i think i find it contrived
because of the different angles
and imbalanced and uh certainly the the
window on the top right hand side
uh looks completely out of character and
unsuitable for the building
thank you council heard so what you're
saying is that we had a
refusal on the imbalance and design of
of the windows
can i sorry help you sometimes yeah
please uh
dude chelsea there's been a number of
issues and i think it's the
the point has also been raised in the
debate was about the number of windows
um i would suggest something
if members were to look in this
direction
uh would be that the proposed
development
um is due to a number of unresolved
design elements including a dominant
roof scape
inconsistent fenestration style
unbalanced
roof styles um and
similar the last couple other cinematics
um
and you know would be detrimental to the
characters appearance of the area
something along those lines and then
obviously get the exact wording
delegated to officers and
through uh and in consultation with
yourself and the world members but
something more along those lines
but i think would sum up the debate
maybe slightly more
thank you sharon okay thank you mr lee
mr
councilman i'm i'm happy to go with that
and uh my compliments to
mr lee for his uh um his choice of words
thank you is there a seconder for that
counselor
yes
okay bernard can we now take the vote on
the amended proposal
as to chairman i've got my hand up
for you
oh sorry
cancer bill yeah it's only a little land
right um i think within the reasons for
refusal as well
is the fact that a lot of this stuff is
retrospective
it's not been built to what has been
approved
surely that's gotta have some sort of
say in it you know if you get approval
you build it to the approval you don't
make it up as you go along
and add this and that after the event
thank you thank you council bill i'm i'm
sure that the officers will put the
wording together
just for clarity i'll say that the fact
that it's retrospective is not a reason
for refusal
um the legislation allows applications
to be
submitted after the work has been
undertaken and
that is not something however much
palatable we find it as decision makers
is not something that we can
use for a reason for refusal would be
very dangerous approach to take
thanks chairman thank you okay burnout
if i can come back please yes cancer
bill
yeah what about the fact that it was
given approval for a specific design
and it's not been built to what was
approved
um mr lee can you answer
thank you chairman um the system allows
you to do that
it you know there is no that is not
something
you know you know you can submit 15 100
different applications if you wanted and
they all could be approved you know
you could then choose which one you want
to do or you could then still not
build it in accordance with them and
submit a further one once it was being
constructed the system allows it
it is not a reason for refusal thank you
chairman
thank you uh okay uh council shauna c
you're muted
thank you chairman um there has been a
precedent
um on our ward um where
um something uh before
uh planning approval was built um and
it had to come down um you know
just saying thank you i'm going to
council sure okay
i think now that we have uh we've
debated this now
and i think that uh if ever we all agree
or we vote on it
that the reason for refusal is dedicated
to the officers
uh as laid out by mr lee five minutes
ago
so can we have a vote on this now please
to do that
thank you cancer thank you chairman can
i just
confirm who seconded the actual
counter proposal um i did
cancer thank you very much so members
we're going to vote now for
to refuse the application as proposed by
councillor herd
with the actual reasons for refusal
delegated to officers in consultation
with the chairman and ward members
i will call your names in alphabetical
order can you please state clearly
for against our abstain starting with
councillor beale
four
councillor edwards oh
the head for a
legend
thank you councillor stilts against
mr swain
thank you members that's seven for the
refusal of the application
two against no abstentions thank you
chairman
thank you so that is carried then that
this application has refused for the
reasons mentioned um item eight any
other items of business business that
the chairman of the committee decides
are urgent i have none
item nine closure of the meeting members
thank you for your contributions this
afternoon i know draw your attention
and i'll draw the meeting to a close at
eight o'clock
as the meeting is now closed members are
advised not to enter into any further
discussion on this forum and to please
leave the meeting promptly
thank you thank you for your code
mr giles and mr thank you for your
attending mrs weisman thank you for
attendance
thank you thank you
bye chairman
you